- It's when you walk in
on your parents having sex
and you are so petrified
that your whole face
goes white, you have ghost cheeks.
- That's happened to you before, yeah?
- Literally.
(upbeat music)
- Hey guys, Christian Zamora here
at the Grammys Red Carpet,
and we're gonna play a game
to see if celebrities know the definition
to Urban Dictionary words.
Are you familiar with Urban Dictionary?
Well I live in the urban dictionary.
- Oh, okay
- It's called Chicago.
- I know what the youths be saying.
- All right, first word: ghost cheeks.
- Ghost cheeks?
- Dead cheeks, like they're just like
- If she has a (word censored)
until you look for it.
She has a fake (censored)
like that (censored)
wasn't really there.
- Is that when you slap a girl's booty
so hard that it disappears?
I don't know.
- Have you done that?
- No, I'm just guessing.
- It's when you use a toilet seat and it's
a little warm from the last person.
- I hate it!
No!
- Some people like that, apparently.
All right, next one: dankrupt.
- You're not as well-endowed
as you thought you were.
- Ooh, that's where you
spend all your money
buying weed, you dankrupt.
- I'm out of weed?
- Yes!
- Hey!
- There you go.
- There we go, I'm cool.
- Okay, I shoulda got that.
- Yo, what is it, who
created these things bro?
- Do we know the feeling? No?
- Um, no, never
- Let's move on.
All right, okay, clam jam.
- See another sexual one.
- Sounds like when someone has a wedgie,
kind of like a camel toe.
- A clam jam is like a intimate party,
so it's like clothes
off, but it's jammin'.
- Oh that's when you're
all up in those clams.
- Like literal clams?
- No, like clam as in vagina.
- It's the female
equivalent to cock block.
- Cock block, okay.
- Have you ever been clam jammed before?
- Absolutely.
- You're trying to talk
to him and she's like
hey, my name is Chelsea.
- Clam Jam hoots nam
- Okay, last one: insta-lurking.
- Oh, we all know what that is man.
- I guess when you spend
too much time on Instagram.
- Going deep and not saying nothing,
being all clandestine and (word censored)
Real CIA.
- That sounds like FBI work.
I've done that before, but you know,
Instagram wasn't around back then,
so what was it, it was like more through
his texts on Skytel two way pagers.
- Have you ever
insta-lurked anyone before?
Maybe Megan, maybe Selena?
- Maybe Selena.
- I have no shame.
I will go through and
like from the beginning,
and it's not an accident.
If you get a like from
me, you know what's up.
I want you to ghost cheek me.
- I now know something.
You taught me something,
right here and right now.